Look, we've always known that
Einstein was better than us.
But now we know why.
Anthony here from D News.
And we are constantly hearing
about Einstein's brain.
It was removed about eight
hours after his death,
and we've just been
poking at it ever since,
looking for the differences that
made it such a brilliant mind.
And a study recently published
in the journal, Brain
thinks that they've
found the answer.
And it's in the corpus callosum,
the body's largest bundle
of neuronal fibers
that sits underneath
your cerebral cortex.
Among its functions
is making sure
that both halves
of the brain can
communicate with each other.
Now, we've talked about the
left brain, right brain myth
and lateralization before.
Spark Notes version--
there's no such thing
as a left or right brain person.
You are a beautiful,
unique snowflake
that can do anything you want,
thanks to practice and neural
plasticity.
However, the things
you do are controlled
by different parts of the brain.
And if those parts
are on different sides
and need to work
together, they've
got to go through the
corpus callosum to do it.
Einstein's corpus callosum had
extremely thick connections
between the halves of three
very interesting brain
regions-- his
prefrontal cortex, which
controls abstract thinking
and decision-making,
his parietal lobe, which is all
about sense and motor function,
and his visual
cortex, for seeing.
The thicker connections could
be responsible for lower
lateralization of brain
activity and at least partially
explain why he was so
brilliant, which is interesting,
because lower
lateralization in the brain
has also been linked to
schizophrenia and psychopathy.
So how do you get
brain like Einstein's?
Last week, I talked a little
bit about neural plasticity
and how the more you use
a part of your brain,
the stronger it gets and the
thicker its connections become.
So in theory, to
think like Einstein,
you've got to do
activities that will
keep your corpus
callosum active and use
both hemispheres of
your brain at once.
Multiple studies have
shown that musicians
tend to use their
whole brain more.
Einstein himself
was a violinist.
So maybe taking up an instrument
or music lessons could help.
Handedness is connected
to lateralization.
So by being
left-handed, I'm using
the right part of
my motor cortex.
A 2004 study in Nature
showed that juggling
could help me strengthen
up my whole brain activity
by requiring me
to use both hands.
Just using your
non-dominant hand
throughout the day for things
like brushing your teeth
could potentially
do the same thing.
Logic and math puzzles are
good, because number estimates
and comparison use both
halves of your parietal lobe.
And if you're terrible
at them, like me,
it means you also get to
work out your amygdala, yor
ventral medial prefrontal
cortex, and your limbic system
by flying into a rage.
Just remember to
flip the desk over
with your non-dominant hand.
I have some issues.
Anyway, an unanswered
question here
is whether Einstein was
born with a more developed
corpus callosum to
begin with, which
would have given this sort
of thinking a head start.
I also cannot tell you with
a straight face that brushing
your teeth with the wrong hand
or playing the ukelele is going
to turn you into the
next great thinker.
But making conscious
decisions to learn, adapt,
and be creative
every day can't hurt.
What do you think?
Was Einstein born better, or
did he make himself that way?
Let me know down below, and
subscribe for more D News.